Because I somehow had to get a job,
and
somehow I had to get a job, I was aspiring to work at a somehow glamorous policy company,
but it turned out to be completely different from what I had imagined, and I
easily quit because I'm black
[Music]
Now that I think about
it, what I longed for was a borrowed dream that someone else
could somehow imagine.
Whose dream was it to become small?
You really wanted to be the one you are now, and this is the job you have now.  If you got a job, then
the opinion of an irritated old man
doesn't matter to you.
[Music]
I'm
fine. Just
say it quickly.
Women are no good. Yukari-san, we've been able to talk about a lot of things, but from now on,
Yukari-san
[Music] I
rubbed your back.  Sometimes I remember
when I was little,
on my first flight,
when I got drunk and felt sick, C's older sister
gently rubbed my back, and
that made me so happy that I wanted to be like her when I grew up.
So this is my dream.I really like my current job.It's a
dream, is
n't it?That's the kind of job I have too.
[Music]
Somehow,
today was
like a party.
[Music]